it's natural that we feel worried when
there's a new threat to our health
identified Dr Dina Hinshaw held the
title of Alberta chief medical officer
of Health for almost exactly one year
before providing this update on a virus
that had locked down an entire city in
China and was spreading across the globe
the risk to albertans is currently very
low a few short months later everything
changed covid-19 had arrived in Alberta
today I'm here to announce that the
first presumptive case of covid-19 has
been detected in Alberta two weeks later
Alberta's first coveted 19 death as
heartbreaking as this news is it was
expected
this is a dangerous virus under her
guidance Alberta implemented strict
rules businesses closed students were
sent home Gatherings were prohibited and
these virtual covid-19 updates became
the norm
Dr Hinshaw became something of a rock
star hailed for her calm demeanor her
focus on science and her words of
compassion for confused and anxious
albertans now more than ever kindness
matters her face soon adorned t-shirts
along with other female Health leaders
like doctors Teresa Tam and Bonnie Henry
but Hinshaw soon found herself fighting
not only covid-19 but politics too as
cases skyrocketed and vulnerable seniors
in Long-Term Care Homes died in record
numbers a story was published using
secretly recorded audio in which Hinshaw
described an uphill battle working with
then Premier Jason Kenny's government I
am profoundly disappointed this is a
personal betrayal a third wave in Spring
2021 would see measures reintroduced but
also the availability of safe and
effective vaccines on the tail end of
that wave a decision that would turn
even the medical community against
Alberta's top doctor the open for summer
plan in which Dr Hinshaw recommended
dropping nearly all public health
measures and ditching the main pillars
of Alberta's coveted response test trace
and isolate I believe that this plan
will work for Alberta but it will take
all of us Dina Henshaw has lost the
moral authority to be our Public Health
leader we want resignation as predicted
cases swelled again in September and
October of 2021 pushing Alberta
hospitals to the brink as a last resort
The Province introduced a vaccine
passport to allow businesses to continue
operating while alienating albertans who
chose not to get vaccinated record high
hospitalizations stretched into the new
year before lower case counts finally
allowed the province to lift
restrictions in a phased approach in
June of 2022 Hinshaw's regular updates
came to an end while she made it through
the worst of the pandemic with her job
Kenny did not the UCP turned on its
leader due largely to his handling of
the pandemic and he resigned Paving the
way for Danielle Smith who immediately
promised a health care overhaul I will
be developing a new team of Public
Health advisors starting with a woman
who was the face of Alberta's journey
through covet 19.